president trump is in line to be the
first president since ronald reagan to
choose
three supreme court justices that would
create the court's biggest
ideological shift in decades joining us
now is white house press secretary kaley
mcnamany
to join us to discuss kaylee very good
to see you this morning i know you guys
were up
all weekend you had a lot to think about
but let's start with this
62 percent of americans say kaylee say
the vacancy left by ginsburg
should be filled by whichever candidate
wins this upcoming election
do you see any way any scenario that
president trump will go along with that
62 percent of voters asked this weekend
the president
is clear in saying that he will be
nominating someone to the supreme court
in fact 29 times in history a president
in their last
year of their term has in fact nominated
someone and been considered by the
senate so the president
will be following that precedent and we
believe that voters
will be supportive of this move as we
move forward and they see the quality of
our nominee
joe biden says this is just an exercise
in raw power
jamming it at the very last minute
jamming it down people's throats
that's not unpredictable for him to say
but what do you think about that
at the white yeah i would refer uh
former vice president joe biden to his
own words when he said that
he in fact would appoint a supreme court
nominee
i'm in the in if there were even just a
few months before an election he said
that
so too did president barack obama and
senator kamala harris among other
democrats so i would point them to their
own words
just a few short years ago like haley if
we're going to point to the
refer you to your old words game you've
got senator graham
senator mcconnell senator cruz who all
said something very different in 2016.
is this really just all about politics
who's ever in power whoever has the
votes
that's how it goes folks no as leader
mcconnell has made clear 2016 was a
different circumstance because we did
have divided government
because we did have democrats in control
excuse me republicans in control of the
senate
um and you had a democrat president now
you have
unified government in the sense of the
senate being republican the president
being republican
uh in fact expanding their majority in
2018 so we do believe it's a different
circumstance
so when will the president announce his
nominee do you think
yeah in the coming days it will be a
very quick turn of event scale so i
think
this yes you will certainly be hearing
this week who that nominee is so
before wednesday i think that's very
likely but i'll leave that to the
president
[Laughter]
all right so far we have senator
murkowski and senator collins on record
are saying listen
nothing should happen at this particular
time is the president going to
do number one do you guys think you have
the votes and if you don't have the
votes is he planning to reach out to
senators
who have broken rank like senator mitt
romney
yes so we do think that we will end up
having the votes um we encourage
um republican senators to take a look at
this nominee we're putting forward
it will be a very talented woman the
president did confirm
that it will be a woman so we do think
that it will be of course a tight
around we know justice ginsburg in fact
um who we honor her legacy here at the
white house
she was confirmed in 42 days so it can
be done and we think it will be done
can you confirm who's on his short list
and by shortlist i mean number one and
number two
so i won't get out of the president and
announcing but many qualified women
there have been some
news reporting out there um and these
qualified women certainly are on his
list he has in fact put forward two
lists
um so we do know unlike past presidents
exactly what those names would look like
and it will be someone
on one of those two lists all right
kaley thank you very much for taking the
time i know you guys are going to be
working overtime these next few days
thank you
that's right thank you gail